We've already studied the
IS curve in some detail
and just a bit of a review here,
it's just relating real
interest rates to real GDP.
Let me just write that as Y, real GDP.
The relationship, there's
2 ways we've viewed it;
one is real interest
rates driving investment
which drives real GDP
or I should say real interest rates
driving planned investments
which drives real GDP.
If you have a high real interest rate
then you're not going to
have as much plan investment
and if you looked at our Keynesian cross,
it's pretty clear
that if you don't have as
high planned investment
you will not have as high of a GDP
or high of a real GDP.
Similarly, if you have a
lower real interest rate
you'll have more planned investment
and then you will have a higher real GDP.
Our IS curve looks like this.
Our IS curve is downward sloping.
It's easier for me to draw a dotted line.
Right over there is our IS curve,
stands for investment savings curve.
This right here is taking it much more
from the investment side,
how real interest rates drive investment.
You could also view it
from the other angle.
You could view how real GDP drives savings
which drives interest rates.
That interpretation, at low levels of GDP
you have less savings.
That's essentially there
is less excess capital
to go around and so it is scarce.
The price of that is expensive
and the price of money is interest rates
and if we're dealing in real
terms, real interest rates
and so it would be high.
If you have higher GDP
and everything else is held constant,
if government spending is held constant,
consumer spending will go up
but it won't go up as high as GDP.
You're going to have more savings,
there's more stuff to lend around
and so the price that's
asked for lending that money
will go down and that price
is real interest rates.
These are two ways of viewing it.
This is the savings driven way
and this is the real interest rates
driving investment.
So that's why it's called the IS curve,
investment savings curve.
Now, what I want to talk
about is the LM curve, LM.
Let me draw a little line over here
although I'm going to
plot it on top of this
so that we can start thinking
about the equilibrium level
of real interest rate and real GDP.
The LM curve, LM stands
for liquidity preference
money supply.
Liquidity preference money supply.
Liquidity preference, it
sounds like a fancy thing
but it's actually a very basic,
it's a very basic idea.
This is, if we hold real money constant
and when I talk about real money.
Let me clarify here.
If I talk about real money,
we're talking about the
amount of money in supply
if we adjust for something like inflation.
You could measure real money,
in the U.S. you could
measure it as base money
or maybe the total amount
of federal reserve notes
or M0.
You could measure it as
M0 divided by the CPI.
Maybe M0 goes up
but if the CPI goes up by the same amount,
by the same percentage
then you're not going to
have a change in real money.
If M0 goes up without prices increasing
then real money has gone up.
If M0 stays constant but
prices have increased
then real money has gone down.
All liquidity preference is describing is
if we assume this is constant
at any given level here,
assume constant,
then the more economic
activity that there is
the more demand that
there is for that money
and so there will be
higher real interest rates.
People will be willing to pay
higher prices for that money
in real terms.
All it's saying is if you have very,
let's start over here,
if you have a lot of economic activity
people will want to hold currency
so that they can have transactions
so they have some flexibility.
The money itself is going to
be circulating much, much more.
There's going to be higher
demand for that money.
If there's higher demand for that money
people will either be willing to pay more
for access to that money
or you're going to have to pay them more
for them to give you their money
because they really want that liquidity.
They really want that
access to their money.
And the price of money is interest rates.
For the LM curve, when we think
about liquidity preference,
holding real money constant,
high levels of GDP,
a lot of economic activity,
people want to have currency,
demand for currency is high
so the price is currency is high
which is real interest rates
and so we would have
real interest rates high
due to liquidity preference.
On the other side of that,
if you have low economic
activity people might say,
"Well, there's not as
much demand for currency,
"there's fewer transactions going on."
And so you will have to pay someone less
to part with their money
or if someone's willing to pay less
in order to get access to money.
So at low levels of GDP,
according to liquidity preference,
you're going to have
lower real interest rates.
Our LM curve looks something like this,
this is IS in this dotted line yellow
and our LM curve looks
something like that.
When you plot these two
constraints against each other
the IS is telling us a relationship
between real interest
rates driving investment
and how that affects GDP
or how real GDP affects savings
affecting real interest rates.
It's a different constraint
that what liquidity
preference is telling us.
This is how much people as
things get better and better,
more and more economic activity,
people want to hold more money.
These two different constraints,
now you take them both into consideration,
you end up with an equilibrium point.
There is going to be 1 point
that meets both constraints
and this is the point at which
the economy is at equilibrium
Real interest rates and real GDP.
Now, let's think about what would happen
if the federal reserve decided to print,
if we'd take a U.S. focus,
if the Central Bank or the federal reserve
decides to print more money?
By this definition up
here of our real money
in the very short term,
especially when we put
our Keynesian hat on,
we assume in the very short
term prices are sticky.
This, in the very short term,
this doesn't change much.
If this goes up then real money goes up
especially in the short term.
Real money goes up.
If real money goes up,
you're essentially increasing
the supply of real money.
Anytime you increase
the supply of real money
at any given level of demand,
people are going to
want to pay less for it.
So what you're going to have happening is,
so at any given level of GDP
there's now more money there.
The price of that money
is going to be less,
the prices of real interest rate.
If the federal reserve, if
the central bank prints money
and real money increases,
we're assuming in the very short term
that prices don't change
because they're sticky
so real money has gone up,
the price of that real money will go down
at any given level of GDP.
That would shift the LM curve down
and so we can start to
see what would that do
to our equilibrium interest
rates and level of GDP.
In that situation, real interest rates,
the equilibrium real interest
rates clearly went down.
We also see, based on this model,
some expansion of GDP.